you have a lot of thoughts on only fans
so i do
what are what are some of the first
things that come come to mind about only
fans
the first thing that comes to mind for
me is you know if you're a grown woman
and that's something that you want to do
by all means i do not want to infringe
on people's right to go and do that
where i took issue with that platform in
particular was being on social media and
seeing it pushed so hard for young women
saying that this is a not only is this a
career alternative but this is something
that's going to make you hundreds of
thousands if not millions of dollars
which is a lie for the most part of
course if you're one of their top
creators that's the money you're gonna
get but i was just scrolling through
social media and of course they curate
these pages for you based on your
demographics and your age and what they
think you're gonna like or at least be
susceptible to and it was all of these
young women saying you know if you need
a sign to go beyond only fans and sell
your pictures yeah here's my bank
account and i make eighty 000 a month
doing this and i saw just all these
young girls i'm talking like 13 14 15
commenting well as soon as i turn 18
this is what i'm gonna do i can't wait
like who needs to go to school who needs
to pursue a career when you can just do
this as your career and that i just
think culturally is
probably a no-no for
our future i would imagine it's not
gonna not gonna look up
yeah yeah i think the issue i've had
with that is
people play it off as if it's not as if
it's fine right they're like oh do this
for a while it's fine like maybe things
change maybe you drop it later but like
you do that kind of thing
and you're not going to feel good about
yourself right and i i don't and i
honestly don't think i believe that
there are people
maybe there's the very rare individual
that does that and is like yeah i'm fine
it's fine but i don't think that makes
people feel good about themselves and i
think like saying that it's fine it is a
lie
i completely agree with you i think it's
a veneer that they put on i think money
shields that a little bit too yeah i was
looking into it it was like the average
uh income that you make from only fans
is somebody just starting out it's like
180 a month so you're getting all of
these young women to go like oh yeah i'm
gonna make so much money here's my
pictures and you never get to take that
back and you have to think that even the
women who are super successful have to
be
experiencing some form of like
psychological trauma walking around and
not knowing who has seen you naked or
who has just got to experience your body
in a way that is so intimate and i yeah
i'm just with you on that one i think
it's a total veneer of people saying
this is positive and i don't mind it at
all
yeah and then like you said they prey on
really young people so at like 17 or 18
or 19 or
20
21 even i think like i'd say probably
anything under 23 uh
that that idea of having money
especially when you don't have any so
like if you're in university or
something you're like i don't have you
know i have money barely to cover
groceries and that's about it but it's
like this is easy
like i'm already kind of doing it on
instagram just to go a little bit
further dude on only fans but then you
know like i said these advertising
agencies that advertise only fans so
basically only fans um offer it as an
alternative and it's not something that
it's going to make you feel good once
you can think more properly i would say
a little bit older it is legitimately
just a massive massive trick and i can
understand why young people fall for it
like when i was in high school i would
always joke about you know oh when i
graduate i'm just going to be a stripper
and that's what's going to pay for my
calling yeah yeah exactly i don't know
like to joke people have i had that as
well certainly my friends be so much
easier stripping yeah
yeah and you think that
you think that and because but it's not
at all it really isn't and it's not
going to pay off your house it's not
going to pay off your college but i
could see like if you're a young person
growing up in this climate right now and
you're looking at like how expensive
higher education is if you are not
particularly happy with the minimum wage
if you're looking at how devastatingly
difficult it can be to buy a house how
you'd be like oh i'll just sell my body
for a few years and then we'll forget
about that and move on but you don't
move on that's the thing
yeah and you don't forget about it
no and i just imagine like you you do
only fans and then like 15 years later
you're sending your kid to school and
the other kids find out that your mom
has naked pictures on the internet just
i can only imagine all the horrible ways
that it could go wrong
yeah there are a lot of them
uh
okay
i have to be very careful about some of
these questions okay no worries